am freitag trifft der slowakische
verteidigungsminister jaroslaw naht zu
einem kurzbesuch in einer
verteidigungsministerium ein grund für
den besuch sind aber weniger bilaterale
gespräche mit verteidigungsminister in
georgia
vielmehr freut sich der
verteidigungsminister auf ein
wiedersehen mit 34 soldatinnen und
soldaten vom österreichischen bundesheer
ich bin so dankbar und freue mich sehr
dass ich heute persönlich in wien sein
kann
nach 16 bis 17 monaten im amt hat es die
kopie situation nicht früher zugelassen
persönlich nach österreich zu kommen
der grund für den besuch liegt also
bereits monate zurück österreich
unterstützen können österreich reagiert
punkt aus 134 soldatinnen und soldaten
zur unterstützung speziell bedanken
möchte ich mich bei diesen 34 heldinnen
und helden die uns bei den massen
testungen zu hilfe gekommen sind
sie waren da als man sie wirklich
gebraucht haben und wie sich
herausstellen sollte waren sie
tatsächlich zum richtigen zeitpunkt am
richtigen ort denn als die krone tests
vor dem gang sind bricht in der
warteschlange plötzlich ein junge
slowake zusammen
die österreicher erkennen den ernst der
lage sofort und greifen mit all ihrer
medizinischen ausrüstung ein dieser
lebensrettenden einsatz bleibt bei der
slowakischen regierung nicht unerkannt
speziell bei den vier lebensrettern
möchte ich mich noch einmal besonders
bedanken
für sie habe ich heute noch eine
spezielle medaillen mitgebracht und
damit haben die österreichischen helfer
nun wirklich nicht gerichtet die
wertschätzung
wir haben am ersten tag bereits einen
besuch des praktischen
verteidigungsministers erhalten auch der
innenminister war dort und wir bekamen
auch bereits am ende des ersten einsatz
woche hinter seine urkunde und ich
glaube es hat keiner von uns damit
gerechnet dass eine einigung funktion
mit allen vergabe noch erfolgen wird und
daher ist die freude für
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
ist dieser tag gehen tag der freude und
ein tag wo wir danke sagen müssen an
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten und auch
da an den verteidigungsminister kollegen
der sich nicht nehmen lassen unsere
soldaten nach auszuzeichnen
[Musik]